there was a time way back in another era
when the goal of the education system
was to educate students and back in
those days the goal was pursued through
a merit-based approach kids were graded
and ranked based on their performance
High performing students were Advanced
on low-performing students were held
back well-behaved students were rewarded
poorly behaved students were punished
that was the general idea but this
strategy has fallen out of favor in
recent years it was too mean we were
told and racist too somehow piece by
piece the system of merit-based
Education Public Schools was dismantled
until finally there was nothing less
left and into that Gap came Equity to
replace it
what does equity mean exactly well
that's a question you'll never get a
real answer to but in this case we know
what Equity means from a practical
perspective it means spending more money
for worse schools it also means creating
new schools from the ground up because
the only way to guarantee that you're
not perpetuating white supremacy is to
start from scratch
one of these new non-racist schools was
founded five years ago in Akron Ohio
with help from NBA All-Star Lebron James
this was a big deal we were assured at
the time NBC News was on the scene when
the school launched watch
kids arrive for the first day of school
today in Ohio as a new approach to fix
an old problem take Center Court led by
someone who knows their stories more
than they could imagine which is why NBA
superstar LeBron James and his
foundation are opening this school in
Akron for at-risk third and fourth
graders who struggle both in school and
at home the most important thing that we
can give them
is structure and a sense of they just
want someone to feel like they like we
care
Now NBC News touts this school as a new
approach to fix an old problem the most
important thing LeBron James says is in
test scores or grades or any objective
sense of achievement whatsoever instead
the key is giving students quote the
sense that someone cares about them
that's not really an educational
Approach at all it's simply a cliche not
a new one either
but it's one that taxpayers in Ohio have
been compelled to fund as one local news
report puts it quote the district will
pay more than half the cost for the
school perhaps around 75 percent that
total amounts to nearly 10 million
dollars a year charged to taxpayers for
this I promise school yet the experiment
was well worth the cost the media
reassured us over and over again you can
go back over the past several years and
find many many media reports gushing
over LeBron's school calling for more
schools just like it
maybe we should even make LeBron James
the Secretary of Education while we're
at it why not
NBC News would certainly be on board
with that just a month ago they were on
the scene again to do a follow-up story
on the I promise school and they say
it's all been a smashing success watch
five years ago NBA superstar LeBron
James opened the I promise School in his
hometown of Akron Ohio the goal to give
at-risk youth a place to learn and feel
supported about 1600 students have
attended the school which demands that
its students promise to always do their
best and make healthy choices
proof of that every graduate receives a
college scholarship
now to recap 1600 students have attended
the school they promised to make healthy
choices LeBron James cares about them
Etc all sounds pretty good but
wait a minute NBC News how are the
students actually performing in the
classroom that bit of information was
left out of the report which seems a
little Autumn it wasn't the whole point
of the school to help these children
just a month later now we know exactly
why NBC News overlooked that little
detail a new piece in the Akron Beacon
Journal reports that quote this Fall's
class of 8th graders at the I promise
School hasn't had a single student pass
the state's math test
since the group was in the third grade
now to restate they haven't had a single
student in the eighth grade class passed
the state math test since they started
at the school in the third grade five
years ago
that is not encouraging
and to be honest it's a little
surprising because not all that long ago
the school claimed in a documentary that
its students do extremely well on
mandatory proficiency tests including
the so-called map standardized tests so
here are some clips from that
documentary in chronological order it's
from YouTube Originals it's an hour and
a half long to talk about how great the
school is it's got three million views
on YouTube
see what impression you come away with
when you watch this watch
the true test of our We Are Family
approach will be when our students take
the math test
map stands for measures of academic
progress our third graders have to pass
the map test in order for them to move
on to fourth grade
since most of our kids started a year
and a half or more below grade level we
have some work to do
they need to make more than one year's
growth by March
if you don't pass the test then
you just have to stay in third grade and
then you do it all over
that's the last thing that a kid wants
to happen to them is them to get held
back
that is that is a very embarrassing
thing and it can play with your emotions
it can play with your psyche your
confidence good morning team IPS
we are going to take our last
administration of the math assessment
we've been working so hard since the
beginning of the year that day Michelle
FaceTiming she was like are you sitting
down she never FaceTime me by the way
and I was like oh no what happened one
of our kids please don't tell me
something to happen with one of our kids
she was like our test scores just came
back and our kids just completely
destroyed them
the same kids a few months ago that was
like in the lower lower percentile and
everything
what
what good question the students
destroyed the standardized test LeBron
James says uh later in the film a
thrilled administrator says that the
students were at the 25th percentile and
Below but then now 91 percent of
students are meeting their goals and
they're all very happy about this but if
you parse what they're saying carefully
it sounds like an apple storage's
comparison the administrator makes it
sound like the students went from the
25th percentile in the district to The
91st percentile which would be an
extraordinary achievement but in fact
the 91 percent number just refers to
students who are meeting their goals
whatever that means and however that's
defined
they're presenting the data like this in
order to suggest falsely that their new
method of Education was working and
specifically enhancing these test scores
but in fact it was doing exactly the
opposite and in a brief moment at the
very end of the documentary we get some
confirmation of that so watch as an
official with the school admits that the
district is not happy with the students
performance
students can either make progress in
growth or achievement or both growth is
just that year and a half or more from
the beginning of the school year
achievement is whether they're on grade
level
on growth we were in the 99th percentile
but achievement on our state report card
we got enough
the overall percentage of students who
made their grade level markers was too
low to Warrant anything other than
enough
you know we're not there yet
[Music]
so if you're following all this there's
all this celebration from LeBron James
and all the taxpayer-funded
administrators about how good the
school's test results results are and
then they admit that despite this
success this alleged success the school
has somehow received an F
from the district for student
achievement they don't elaborate they
don't tell you that in fact zero of the
students in one class had ever met their
grade level markers for math that seems
like a significant discrepancy
one that the media and taxpayers in
Akron would be very interested and yet
um none of the media Outlets that have
fluffed this school in the past few
years have bothered to cover it
we are days away from the Durbin Accords
the greatest threat to the US Dollar's
Global dominance in the past 80 years on
August 22nd the brics nations are
expected to announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan is to
plant the U.S and the dollar as the
Cornerstone of the Global Financial
system you can protect your IRA or 401K
from The Fallout from this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven in times of high
uncertainty which is right now
unfortunately when currencies fail gold
is a safe haven how much more time does
a dollar have ask yourself that well you
protect your savings with gold Birch
gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers find out why by texting
wolves to 989898 and get your free info
kit on gold if a central bank digital
currency becomes a reality it'll be nice
to have some gold to depend on again
text Walsh to
989898 companies are strong arming their
customers to support abortion canceling
customers for their political views and
making a mockery of women by supporting
transgender models no government agency
institution or companies allowed to just
be what it is and focus on fulfilling
the tasks that it was made to fulfill a
beer company can't just make beer
anymore their primary concern is not
with brewing and distributing beer but
with showing their support of the left's
political and cultural agenda well
Public Square offers a new solution
Public Square is an app and website
where you can get connected to tens of
thousands of businesses from all
different industries that share your
value for Life family and freedom Public
Square also offers discounts to many
high profile businesses on uh on black
platforms that you can actually have an
incentive to spend money with because
the companies don't hate you well
whether you're looking for a new
athletic clothing that knows what a
woman is a banking partner you can count
on or simply a new restaurant in your
area that won't lecture you about your
political views as you're trying to
enjoy a meal with your family head over
to publicesq.com Public Square it's free
to join as a consumer or a business
owner you can get started at
publicsq.com or download their app today
that's publicsq.com
that documentary we just showed you has
been out for almost two years NBC News
must have missed it
the truth is that corporate media didn't
want to look too deep into the data
because it's not just bad it's terrible
and it keeps getting worse the more you
read it as the Albany Beacon Journal
reports the the English scores for the
eighth graders were not much better than
the math numbers quote when the School's
First Class of eighth graders graduated
from my promise just 11 of them tested
proficient on the state English language
arts test the article goes on two of I
promises biggest subgroups of students
black students and those with
disabilities are now testing in the
bottom five percent in the state Landing
the school on the Ohio Department of
education's list of those requiring
targeted intervention
now you often hear the counter argument
that this is a school for troubled
children so of course their scores are
going to be low that doesn't exactly
explain why the scores are going
backwards according to the data quote
last year sixth graders lost ground when
they were in fifth grade seven percent
were proficient on the reading tests in
sixth grade just two percent were
now
the point here is not to gloat over the
failure of this experiment in some ways
it's a noble effort admittedly I'm not a
fan of LeBron James personally I'll be
the first to admit that he's a woke
virtue signaler to such a degree that he
pretends to read books about Malcolm X
you've probably seen this clip before
but honestly it's just too good to not
share again uh here it is
yeah um so you're holding the
autobiography of Malcolm X along with
Alex Haley I don't know how far you are
into the boat but what's your biggest
takeaway so far
um I kind of just started a couple days
ago
but um I've read and a lot of a lot of
notes over the years it's my first I'm
actually reading this from start to
finish
but just a very um
very smart man
very very smart man
and basically
um
his words and in the 60s
and uh and what was going on
is actually what's going on today still
that's the guy who's going to reinvent
our nation's educational system with his
bold new approach
the guy who was still failing his book
reports at the age of 38. now
even if it's kind of funny to have a
school run by a guy who pretends to read
books and even if aside from that LeBron
James is a reckless liar who regularly
promotes BLM propaganda Slanders police
officers Etc I can still respect a rich
celebrity athlete at least attempting to
do something productive which is more
than what most of them will do
but the reason for the school's failure
is what's instructive here according to
the accepted narrative kids from quote
marginalized groups struggle in school
especially inner city schools because of
systemic racism and a lack of funding
two issues that we're told are very
related
so here's a School founded by a wealthy
black man with an extraordinary amount
of funding both from taxpayers and
LeBron's Foundation a school where
everybody gets free lunch and they have
access to all of the state-of-the-art
Educational Tools and all the computers
and everything and they're they're
teaching based on stem and they're doing
all this and everyone graduates with a
scholarship and so on
yet the kids are still failing
I mean when it comes to math literally
all of them are failing in eighth grade
anyway
in fact they seem to be doing worse than
they would in one of those allegedly
underfunded schools where the vestiges
of systemic racism are still allegedly
present
and we have data on that the way that I
promise select students is via a lottery
in which students who place in the
bottom 25 percent of test scores in the
district are eligible
but if you compare the I promise
students with kids in the bottom 25 in
the district who did not attend the
school the kids who didn't attend are
doing better by most metrics
now this tells us a few things all of
them are forbidden truths
the most important is that all of the
funding and all of the inspirational
platitudes in the world
cannot make up for broken families and
bad culture
poor black kids come from both of those
things and the two are obviously related
you will not be able to measurably
improve any aspect of life for these
kids especially their educational
performance without addressing the fact
that the culture they come from is
deeply sick
and their families are an absolute
disarray
just talk to any teacher who's ex has
experience trying to teach these
so-called quote-unquote marginalized
groups very often uh the teachers will
tell you
that their behavior and attitude in
class it's not just bad it's like
appalling it's abominable
these kids who have not received any
kind of intellectual or moral formation
at home or in their communities
in many cases their parents do not care
about their education or about anything
the culture they're brought up in
encourages them to act in outrageous
ways and reject and disrespect all
authority
that's the fact of the matter
that's the problem
that's how you end up with kids in the
eighth grade who all of them can't even
do math
now LeBron James can't solve all of
those problems on his own of course but
he could start by at least acknowledging
them and talking about them
but he won't even do that
as always the left seeks to solve
problems without addressing the
underlying fundamental issues it's like
their genius plans to solve homelessness
by putting the homeless in hotels or
giving them free housing
well you can give a homeless guy a room
at the Ritz Carlton and the place will
look like a garbage dump within a span
of three hours
and that'll be right back out on the
street
that's because the homeless guy's
problem isn't that he doesn't have a
home
any halfway competent and sober person
can manage to find some kind of housing
okay if you're sober and halfway
competent you're not going to end up
sleeping on a box on the street corner
you just won't
his problem isn't a lack of housing it's
that he's a drug addict or psychotic or
both
so it would be one thing if some
coherent principal was at play here but
there's nothing coherent about any of
this
consider that the left solution to
education homelessness is to throw money
at the problem
but their solution to law enforcement is
to do exactly the opposite
so somehow the education system will
improve if you give more money
but the justice system will improve if
you give it less money
how does that make sense
you'll never see any contemplation from
this on the left instead they'll
continue to push the most destructive
policies imaginable only to backtrack
when the consequences of their
destruction are too obvious to deny
which is happening right now in Oakland
by the way the president of the naacp's
Oakland chapter
just announced that quote failed
leadership including the movement to
defund the police our district
attorney's unwillingness to charge and
prosecute people who murder and commit
life-threatening serious crimes and the
proliferation of anti-police rhetoric
have created a Heyday for Oakland
criminals
oh you think congratulations NAACP you
finally realized that crime is bad
a stunning revelation
but of course they are also incapable of
tracing the problem down to its roots
the NAACP supports blm's Insanity when
it gave them power and now they're
against it because It embarrasses them
that's all there is to it
what happens next when it comes to
education it's possible that once these
people are sufficiently embarrassed by
what they've done to public schools in
this country they'll stop experiments
like the one that's going on in Ohio
right now but by that point as if by
Design it'll be far too late
LeBron James will have moved on
the children won't have that luxury
they'll be uneducated poor and totally
dependent on the government that
pretended to care about them
most people would call that a disaster
but our leaders have another name for it
they call it equity
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there